we'll get to education in a minute but i
just want to start with ukraine and in
particular those comments by president
joe biden for god's sake this man cannot
remain in power
does the uk government also think that
putin has to go
i think that's up to the russian
the russian people i think are pretty
fed up um with what is happening
in ukraine this illegal invasion the
destruction of their own livelihoods
their economy
is collapsing around them and i think
the russian people
will decide the fate of putin and his
cronies the important thing to remember
is that
there is evidence that our war crimes
have been committed
in the ukraine targeting of civilians
areas in the ukraine and
you will know that the deputy prime
minister dominic rabb has been working
with the international criminal court to
make sure that that evidence is well
documented well collected
so that those who commit war crimes know
that there will be a day of reckoning i
mean you're very clear aren't you in
saying that it's for the russian people
to decide who that president is
it's not helpful is it as common from uh
jay biden i mean u.s president's calling
for regime change doesn't always end
well
well i think the white house has been
very clear
um after that uh speech which was a very
powerful speech by president biden
talking about contradict what he said on
well they've been clear that that
actually it is an illegal invasion of
the ukraine and that must end um and i
think that's what the president is
talking about i think it's right
that it is for the russian people to
decide how they are governed i suspect
as i say to you many of them um will
have
friends um indeed family that are
ukrainians and having innocent
ukrainians murdered by putin in his
regime
is not something that sits well with the
russian people
either
so i think it's important to remember
that they will make decide that uh they
will make that decision ultimately so he
was wrong to say that
no i what i'm saying to you is the um
white house has been very clear on this
that the president gave a very powerful
speech on this and i think um it's
both the united states and the united
kingdom agree that it's up to the
russian people to decide uh who should
be governing them they would certainly
do well to have someone um that is
democratic and understand their wishes i
suspect um the majority of russians
see the invasion as illegal and want
this war to end
now there's been talk this week that
russia might be scaling back its
ambition in ukraine that the defense
ministry is saying its main goal was the
liberation of the donbass region in the
east
what's your latest intelligence about
what is actually happening on the ground
in ukraine
well clearly the uh russian uh military
has miscalculated um uh i think uh the
initial um sort of shock and awe of
taking the whole of ukraine
has not worked for them the ukrainians
have fought like lions uh they've
defended their country uh they believe
in their freedom they believe in justice
and the rule of law and their democracy
which is why i think uh the russian
military find it much tougher and
they're losing uh tens of thousands of
innocent uh young men who've been sent
to the front line not knowing why
they're invading a neighboring country
that is democratic and i think uh
they're they're they're paying the price
and maybe a change of strategy than you
think well clearly if you look at the um
ministry of defense's
assessment that we're putting out
they're having real problems
now liz trust has told the sunday
telegraph today that sanctions on russia
should only come off after a full
ceasefire and withdrawal from ukraine so
do you think that's a condition of any
sort of peace deal is that what we're
starting to move towards
it has to be any peace deal has to take
into account the wish of the free
ukrainian people i also think president
zielinski is right about this that any
serious peace deal
has to be negotiated face to face
between president zielinski and putin
that is the only way putin is going to
be serious about this i think the only
thing
that the regime understands
is
the strength of the military response
from the ukrainian military
and of course the strength and resolve
of the ukrainian people so i think
president zielinski is absolutely right
all this
um stuff will not be taken seriously by
him or the ukrainian people unless
putin's prepared to sit down with him
and just to be clear then no sanctions
coming off until there's a full cease
fire and withdrawal
absolutely right i think uh the
russian
illegal invasion has to end and the
russian army has to leave the ukraine
and it's up to the ukrainian people
they must be very much the ones who
decide what that piece looks like
now just to kind of take a step back for
a minute you know we've seen millions of
people displaced from ukraine families
children
you of course came to the uk
your family from
hussain's iraq when you were a boy
you've always said that you were not
refugees but immigrants but at the same
time you know you were a boy you didn't
speak the language
does it bring back i guess memories and
how do you feel some of those children
must be feeling you know you see them
moving
across
continents being thrust into different
places very much so it's
a combination of of anger um um
loss huge loss because you're ripped
away from all those things that you held
at deer and and those sort of protective
layers of family and
home
and you don't understand why this is
happening to you
and so i absolutely feel
uh that which is why
my department um has made preparations
to take up to a hundred thousand
ukrainian children
into our education system from early
years to primary to secondary of course
to colleges and universities and we will
deliver that we did it for the afghan
resettlement scheme uh we're doing it
with the hong kongers 104 000 have
applied to settle here as well how did
you feel then as a sort of
eleven-year-old boy not speaking english
um fear
the first few weeks i um sat in the back
of classroom i hid at the back of the
classroom because children can be cruel
um i tried to string words together in
my head the few words i knew as i began
to obviously read and and write to try
and make a sentence to join in the
subject matter but when i'd um
made that sentence the subject matter
had moved on so the early
few weeks my teachers thought i had
learning difficulties which is why our
green paper is so important
next week but also our white paper as
well because my parents
understood the value of education my
mother used to always say it will unlock
opportunities my son so work hard and
focus on education it's only when i
started to think in the language that
those opportunities really unlocked for
me
i want the system which is why the white
paper is so important to work for every
child to a strong school with a great
teacher
for every child at the right place at
the right time um to deliver that
the white paper i think will
go a long way towards that because that
has to be available for the children
whose parents don't have the wherewithal
or have no parents at all let's talk a
bit about that white paper what is the
big idea then
so the the big idea is learn from the
evidence we are
about to announce our 10 000th academy
so that's real scale i have 22 000
schools approximately in england the
evidence is that a family of schools
that is tightly um supported really well
managed in a strong performing and
underlying strong performing
multi-academy trusts because some of
them
haven't performed as well but the strong
performing ones have delivered
outstanding outstanding results for the
children
and so the white paper will
essentially will be the road map towards
getting all schools into that strong
family of schools with some you know
really strong targets so the moment only
two-thirds 65 percent
of primary school children finish
primary school with the ability to read
write and do maths uh to a a good
standard
we're going to raise that to 90 percent
on
secondary school uh we're going to move
the average in english language and
maths from 4.5 to 5. now that sounds uh
like you know not much of a an ambitious
target it's only point five point
movement but actually it means
all children um who are
doing their gcses will have to improve
those lowest one-third and the higher
chance if a child falls behind in
english amounts what actually happens so
if a child falls behind i have the
national tutoring program which is part
of the five billion we are investing in
recovery
teachers will actually be able to
identify what that is be able to use the
natural tutoring program
it in the past has been the privilege of
fortunate parents wealthier parents now
it's available to every child so my
message to families list watching this
at home is
ask your school
are they participating in national
tutoring program it's a really important
program to help that recovery and of
course help us meet those targets and
you want a longer school day for every
for all schools so the average school
day is 32 and a half hours
some schools thousands of schools are 10
20 30 minutes
lower than that um so we want schools to
be so from 9 00 a.m till 3 30. by the
way if it's 20 minutes lower
than the 32 and a half hours um that is
the equivalent of two weeks
lost from the uh uh the the the uh
school um
two weeks loss of learning is a big loss
which is why i want every school to do
this i'd like them all to do it by the
end of this year but i know some of them
have logistical problems which is why
we've said by next year okay they should
achieve that now so you want all schools
to have this uh
not longer day necessarily but as a
certain amount of hours in a day you
want better teaching or promise to
intervene if children fall behind
the schools have struggled haven't they
with years of effectively underfunding i
just want to show this uh graph that i
think we should be able to bring up now
this is the funding gap between state
and private schools since the
conservatives entered power you can say
the change of funding sorry the the
change of per-pupil funding so you can
see that the blue line is private
schools that's the fees that parents pay
per pupil
private schools the red line is state
school spending per pupil and this is
the change per pupil the dotted line
2010 when the conservatives entered
power
if you're a parent looking at this what
do you think you would conclude about
how the conservatives prioritize state
school pupils so you'll remember in 2009
that was the financial crash and the
crisis that
led to us having
to tighten our belts and of course
um
try and get the economy back on its feet
um thank goodness we managed to do that
because then we got the pandemic where
we've had to spend 400 billion making
sure that people's jobs are protected
and of course businesses are protected
but if you look at the settlement i've
just got
is an additional seven billion
uh by 2024 25 much of it front load
loaded by the way so four billion that
comes early it's effectively restoring
per people funding to 2010 levels you've
got a lost decade haven't you
effectively of
of growth in funding for comprehensive
schools and state school pupils but but
also
you know
as i just explained we had to get
through uh the financial crisis on the
back so it collapsed state schools
well but but the important thing is is
to continue that investment now and
deliver it's not just the 7 billion by
the way i've got 5 billion for recovery
as well part of that is the national
tutoring program
these are important investments in
school and of course teachers have done
a brilliant job if you think of what
they've had to come through including of
course dealing with omicron 99.9 of
schools are open
uh the viruses hasn't gone away you know
we still have uh nine percent absence um
of teaching staff and sports staff um in
schools so um i'm very conscious that we
have to keep
continuing to support the teaching
profession okay the best way to do that
is the vaccination program and of course
we have the booster
and the announcement that we will uh now
go further with protecting the most
vulnerable with a fourth shot um and of
course making sure that we keep
supporting schools uh through both local
direct problems you're talking about the
the pandemic which obviously had a
really very
devastating impact on schools it widened
inequality as well private schools saw a
12 percentage point increase in a stars
last year comprehensive schools a 3.9
increase
you've said that closing schools looking
back was a mistake was cancelling exams
a mistake as well
so i think uh
the secretary of state then had very
little choice would you have done it
once well
one
you
when
the inquiry will look at uh the
decisions made to get the country
through the
would you have done it we've already
cancelled exams
i don't think he's had much choice
the truth is that the closure of schools
um when i reflect on that was a mistake
and i'm on record of saying that and i
will do everything in my power never
again to close schools and the prime
minister absolutely agrees with me
because the
not just the learning loss but actually
the mental strain on young people the
anxiety if you look at what the
children's commissioner has done on
serving half a million children they
said actually they really wanted to be
back at school i was at tottridge
academy um last week and the children
said to me the worst thing that happened
to us is having to be at home and learn
at home i saw it for myself with my own
um uh child so
i will do everything in my power to make
sure we don't do that and part of the
learning to live with covert is very
much around that but it's the teachers
who've done a brilliant job it's a
support staff in schools who've allowed
us to get to this position so we can
live with the virus closing schools was
a mistake
you've got more money for schools so it
by implication there perhaps wasn't
enough uh previously we've talked about
the inequality gap
your predecessor was awarded a
knighthood gavin williamson what was
that for services to boris johnson's
leadership campaign or his record on
education so sophie i'm going to say
something to you which isn't universally
popular i know
but being in the department and you see
this on my lapel here it's t levels
um the skills white paper
and the skills bill which is about to
receive royal ascent
was gavin williamson's work when i was
in the department okay on the there's a
maze so he deserves the skills skills
was considered the cinderella part of
the department gavin williamson's work
on skills t levels the lifelong learning
entitlement will transform the fortunes
of young people in our country who may
not want to go to university i think
for that alone he deserves that night
okay now we're expecting the government
to publish its plan for uh energy next
week with a push on renewables so
there's a bit of a debate over whether
to relax planning laws to allow more
onshore wind farms to be built now in 20
in 2012 you signed a letter opposing
onshore wind have you changed your mind
no i would say that if we are going to
make sure that
uh we carry the will of local people
whether it's onshore wind or nuclear we
have to learn uh from how it's done well
in other countries and the way you do
that is making sure the local community
have a real say uh and what want onshore
wind if that's what they they they want
to have
but also we've seen great examples in
other countries where if they built a
nuclear power station
within a certain
radius of that power station people get
free power so
it's right to look at innovation to make
sure that we wean ourselves off
hydrocarbons we have to do that and have
to do it uh well
part of that is making sure that
we look after the will of the lord just
to clarify then so
do you
agree with the idea that planning law
should be relaxed to allow more onshore
wind farms to be built only if the local
community supports having more onshore
wind i think that's the right thing is
there around cabinet battles at the
minute
no there is no rail because we have
collective responsibility in cabinet we
discuss things and when we agree uh we
take that
agreement seriously and we have
collective responsibility uh now energy
bills obviously are going through the
roof this is why we're looking at these
um innovations uh inflation forecaster
hit 8.7 the resolution foundation
saying that half a million children can
be pushed below the poverty line
rishi sunak is going to have to come up
with more support isn't he
so
we are
today in a global battle against
inflation literally um the the world is
battling this in the u.s in europe we
are too what does that mean
to the consumer your viewers when you're
in a global battle against inflation it
means the cost of
everything from your shopping basket to
your energy bills going up what rishi
did um is to say actually what has
worked is local government know who is
most vulnerable so we've doubled the
size of the health
he's put 22 billion for one year of help
9.1 billion of it for energy and the
rest of it is is things like making sure
that people on universal credit
and the taper they actually keep more of
the money
do you think he has done enough then i
think he will continue to keep an eye on
this it's only right it's irresponsible
for me to say you know job done because
energy prices are volatile
inflation remains high so it would be
absolutely irresponsible to say job done
but what i would say to you is putting
22 billion to work after spending 400
billion in response to the pandemic is
the right thing to do one billion
through local government the universal
credit uh taper on friday
the national living wage will go up
which means a thousand pounds uh for
those additional okay uh a thousand
pounds for those most vulnerable so we
have to continue to keep an eye on this
but i think 22 billion in one year of
help when you've just spent 400 billion
is the right thing to do now i just want
to end by talking about prince william's
caribbean tour and there have been a few
controversial moments i think everyone
will remember the picture
of the fence and prince william the duke
and duchess of cambridge uh reaching out
to kind of touch the hands of some of
those children
um we can see some of the videos of draw
there and now he has acknowledged
growing republican sentiment within the
commonwealth saying that the trip
brought into even sharper focused
questions about the past and the future
he and the duchess of cambridge he said
were committed to service and that for
us that's not telling people what to do
do you think this could be the beginning
of the end for the commonwealth
no i think it'll be the beginning of
strengthening the commonwealth because i
think actually what prince william
and i know
he believes
deeply in the commonwealth is right to
say that
people have to decide independently if
they want to be part of the commonwealth
family
and that
decision will strengthen the
commonwealth not take away from it which
is why i think he's being
very wise and have chosen his worth
carefully okay thank you very much for
being on the programme today at nadine
zahari then